sie sind die beiden kirchen die die welt
wie wir sie kennen verändert
hatten schon immer diese art von
respektlosigkeit als teil ihrer haltung
die sie so kreativ macht diese beiden
gründer halten sich wirklich für
edelmänner sie denken dass das was sie
tun gut für die welt ist
[Musik]
waren die typen die bildung von alice
kanada
ich sagte minister gates was ist ihr
albtraum ich dachte er würde sagen apple
oder netscape oder oracle aber er sagte
ich mache mir sorgen dass jemand in
einer garage eine neue technologie
erfindet microsoft hatte über zwei jungs
in einer garage im jahr 98 nachgedacht
und über ein handgemaltes schild mit der
aufschrift google globales hauptquartier
ein ende in einer branche in der
innovation nur ein teil der
stellenbeschreibung ist sind larry page
und sergey brin zu virtuellen meistern
des universums der
informationsbeschaffung geworden was wir
nicht wissen wie google
und ich dachte die ganze zeit selbst zu
googlen würde was anderes bedeuten nicht
mehr silicon valley ist übersät mit
startups die ins stocken geraten sind
warum diese beiden informatik freaks
erfolgreich waren hat möglicherweise
viel mit dem fast parallelen leben zu
tun dass sie führten bevor sie eines der
größten und mächtigsten unternehmen der
welt gründungen brin und page lehnten es
respektvoll an unserem programm
teilzunehmen
sergey brin wurde 1973 in der
sowjetunion geboren seine eltern waren
mathematiker und juden was ihre
karrierechancen minderte
mag man sieht ist mitautor der gugl
story also ging's herr gates vater zu
einer konferenz in warschau graf eine
ganze reihe von kollegen aus dem westen
sah das leben außerhalb der sowjetunion
kam zurück setzte sich mit der familie
hin und sagte wir müssen gehen seine
eltern brachten eine zielstrebigkeit mit
die sie ihrem sohn bei brachten es lief
auf eine einfache nachricht hinaus bot
camberg öbb kommen nicht mit einem b
zurück com nicht mit dem zweiten platz
zurück sein erster immer gut
verinnerlicht dass es wurde ein kern
seiner persönlichkeit
larry page wurde wie brennen 1973
geboren seine familie lebte in michigan
und sein vater war der erste in seiner
familie der einen hochschulabschluss
hatte beide eltern waren auf ähnlichen
feldern prinz tätig
sie waren informatiker der zweiten
generation was für die damalige zeit
sehr ungewöhnlich war wenn die
informatik entwickelte sich als fach
eigentlich erst in den 60er jahren und
wir hatten beide eltern einen höheren
abschluss
sie sehen sich auf einer mission ob
diese mission entspringt wirklich ihren
biografien
[Musik]
in 2009 teilte paid dieser mission mit
der abschlussklasse der university of
michigan du weiß wie es ist mitten in
der nacht mit einem lebhaften traum
aufzuwachen und wenn du keinen bleistift
und keinen block neben dem bett hast ist
er am nächsten morgen verschwunden ich
hatte einen dieser träume als ich 23 war
ich wachte auf und dachte was wäre wenn
wir das ganze internet herunterladen und
nur die links behalten könnten ich
schnappte mir einen stifter und fing an
zu schreiben kurz danach erzählte ich
meine berater terry minarett dass es ein
paar wochen dauern würde um das web
herunterzuladen
doch er nickt wissend dass es viel
länger dauern würde aber glück genug es
mir nicht zu sagen
stanford professor und ingenieur berater
bei google terry mit larry denkt einfach
an möglichkeiten dinge zu tun die man
vielleicht nicht der wackelt sergej
waleri sehr ähnlich er war auch jemand
der wirklich über den tellerrand schauen
wollte um zu sagen wenn das unmöglich
klingt versuchen wir es war 1995 an der
stanford university als ich die
eigenwilligen überflieger zum ersten mal
trafen
eine ihrer stamford professoren sagte
immer der unterschied zwischen den
beiden vater sergej einfach in mein büro
stürmte ohne zu fragen larry wurde
klopfen und dann herein platzen
[Musik]
in den 90er jahren war die suche im
internet rudimentär auf gut glück
auf duden ergebnisse geliefert die
nutzlos waren und der prozess war sehr
langsam dann haben sie ihre anfrage
eingegeben und erst mal was anderes
gemacht und dann ging man zurück und sah
die ergebnisse und die meisten waren
völlig irrelevant page und brin drängten
auch etwas besser ist
serges großes interesse bestand darin
alle seiten im world wide web zu nehmen
und zu versuchen muster zu finden
sie begannen eine aufnahme von backlinks
zu machen wie sie sie nannten
page bemerkte dass sich hinter jeder
webseite hunderte oder sogar tausende
anderer seiten befanden die darauf
verlinken tut
[Musik]
geht wo es war ein aha moment der das
sogenannte
informationszeitalter verändern würde
dann erkannten sie dass diese liste von
backlinks für das ranking verwendet
werden konnte wenn sie mehr backlinks
haben würde ihnen eine bessere seite
angezeigt wenn viele andere websites mit
einer website verlinkt waren bedeutete
das wahrscheinlich dass die benutzer sie
für goutierten das genie erkannte dass
diese art von algorithmus ihnen die art
von ergebnissen liefern kann die den
suchenden am wichtigsten sind page und
brin hatten ihre geheime formel jetzt
brauchte sie einen namen
die jungs sucht nach einem großartigen
namen der ihre grandiose vision
einfangen würde und stießen auf diese
riesige nummer 1 mit hundert nullen
bekannt als google geoeye
doch sie war schon vergeben also sagten
sie weißt du was lasst uns eine nettere
schreibweise für normale
am 15 september 1997 registrierten sie
google als website und page und brin
brachen ihre promotionen ab um sich auf
die suche nach finanzierungsmitteln für
junges unternehmen zu konzentrieren
es wurde nicht einfach investoren wie
ein schwamm waren skeptisch
zu dieser zeit gab es fünf suchmaschinen
und ich sagte dass vielleicht eine von
ihnen an der technologie interessiert
sein könnte die welt brauchte keine
sechste suchmaschine
[Musik]
google passte einfach nicht zu der
herkömmlichen auffassung davon was eine
website können nämlich die benutzer
davon abzuhalten zu einer anderen seite
zu wechseln google tat das undenkbare es
half benutzern das breitere internet zu
erkunden larry page und sergey brin
waren anderer meinung sie sagten wir
wollen kein portal wir wollen
suchergebnisse in sekundenbruchteilen
larry und sergej saßen also eines
sonntagmorgens bei einem befreundeten
stanford-professor auf der veranda und
andy peckelsheim einer der gründer von
sun microsystems kam in seinem
sportwagen guckte sich eine zehnminütige
demo an sagte fantastisch das ist das
nächste große ding und schrieb einen
scheck über 100.000 dollar ausgestellt
auf google inc steven levy zehn jahre
leiter des magazins wired so laufen die
dinge halt im silicon valley es klingt
erstaunlich dass jemand einfach 100.000
dollar scheck ausstellt damit sie
starten können das ganze geschah auch
für einen gewissen hintergrund sie waren
in stanford ihre professoren hatten das
schon mal gemacht das ist nicht ziemlich
gute wette wir könnten 100.000 euro
verlieren oder den großen gewinn machen
und zu der zeit hatten wir noch gar kein
unternehmen wir konnten den scheck nicht
einließ
es gab keine juristischen dokumente
wissen sie nichts von diesem zeug
und obwohl sie das startgeld hatten
brauchten sie noch viel mehr bargeld
niemand kaufte sich aus unternehmen ein
also gingen sie zurück zur emscher sie
haben drei andere investoren gefunden
und zusammen haben wir genug geld
gesammelt um sie an den start zu bringen
genug geld war eine million dollar
darunter
250.000 dollar von jeff bezos von
amazon.com
page und brin gründeten google am 4
september 98 und zogen in eine dieser
geschichtsträchtigen garagen in menlo
park
sie erregten die aufmerksamkeit zweier
bekannter risikokapitalgeber aus dem
silicon valley michael moritz von
sequoia capital und condor von kleiner
perkins beide wollten einen exklusiven
deal
die beiden hatten damals echt nerven in
ihrem zarten alter von mitte 20 zu sagen
wir wollen kein geld von nur einem
risikokapitalgeber wir wollen
sicherstellen dass keiner von ihnen die
kontrolle hat also spalten wir uns auf
im juni 99 gab google seine erste
pressemitteilung heraus in der die
investition angekündigt wurde 25
millionen dollar rampage musste nun
erstklassige ingenieure einstellen leute
die ihren hohen ansprüchen genügen würde
ist ein ehemaliger googler es war eines
der intensivsten einstellungsverfahren
aller unternehmen weltweit
ich hatte nur wenigen tagen zwischen 12
und 15 interviews sie schufen eine
zentrale namens googleplex mit angeboten
für die mitarbeiter sie kostenloses
essen und kinderbetreuung das informelle
firmen motto don't be evil sei nicht
böse ich aber google verdiente immer
noch kein geld
larry kam rein und ich sagte wie willst
du damit geld verdienen die google
mitbegründer larry page und sergey brin
hatten eine neue suchmaschine entwickelt
mussten aber noch einen weg finden damit
auch geld zu machen
aber sie wollten das nicht mit werbung
zuerst dachten sie werbung so
schmuddelig kommerziell und irgendwie
unpassend sergey brin entwarf die
berühmt spärliche homepage
wahlen yahoo und aol weigerten sich brin
und page ihre seite mit werbung zu
überladen
wir nehmen keine werbung auf die
homepage wir wollen vertrauen aufbauen
und nicht das gefühl haben dass wir sie
mit werbung überhäufen doch keine
werbung bedeutete keine einnahmen page
und brin mussten werbung als einzige
option akzeptieren am anfang gab es
suchmaschinen bei denen die treffer wie
normale suchergebnisse aussahen aber
dinge waren für die die sponsoren die
suchmaschine bezahlkarten und sie sagten
das sei nicht gut für die nutzer ich
will nicht dass von dem andere wollen
dass ich es sehe sondern ich will das
was ich sehen will dann fanden sie einen
kompromiss
sie erfanden eine neue art werbung zu
platzieren
ausgelöst durch suchanfragen ins stadt
liegende anzeigen oder papas erschienen
diese kleinen anzeigen über und neben
den tradierten
heute ganz normal damals revolutionär
sie nannten es google adwords die
unternehmen konnten die kontrolle über
ihre werbegelder übernehmen entgegen sie
anzeigen schlüssel für bestimmte
werbetreibende lieben dieses system weil
sie nur zahlen wenn jemand tatsächlich
auf ihre anzeige klickt für viele
werbetreibende ist es die effizienteste
form des marketings die sie je hatten
für unternehmen war es der heilige gral
eine direkte verbindung zu ihren besten
kunden mit einer massiven neuen
einnahmequelle explodierte
bis september 2000 hatte die seite eine
milliarde url registriert und war in 15
sprachen verfügbar
trotzdem wussten nur wenige leute
außerhalb des silicon valley wer google
erschaffen hat
sergey brin sagte die wahrheit
und täuschte er ist
der echte saverin bitte aufstehen
aber medien mogul wussten genau wer sie
waren barry diller war einer der ersten
traditionellen medien manager der die
google jungs besuchte desaster mit
seinem taschencomputer und schrieb seine
e mails und er sagte larry bitte ich
rede mit ihm können wir uns einfach
unterhalten und er sagt ich kann beides
und barry diller meint nein können sie
nicht wählen sie und er sagt ich wähle
das
mit dem enormen wachstum kamen weitere
herausforderungen auf den süßen google
zu die risikokapitalgeber des
unternehmens
drängten die mitbegründer einem schiff
sie waren dagegen aber sie wollten auch
nicht sagen hey wir könnten das doch
machen obwohl sie dachten sie könnten
das am ende durchliefen sie 12 13 14
interviews aber sie machten keinen von
denen also besuchten sie steve jobs weil
er ein held für sie war
warum kann er nicht unser chef sein
sondern stellte page und brin eric
schmidt von einem geschäftsmann mit
technischem hintergrund
sie haben gerade eric schmidt
eingestellt erst gekommen um google zu
leiten
was steckt dahinter ich meine könnt ihr
das nicht selber machen
elterliche aufsicht um ehrlich zu sein
wissen sie eric ist der erweisen ich
meine er ist mitte fünfzig nicht mit der
30 er hat viel erfahrung er ist
diplomatischer als sie und das braucht
man im umgang mit der traditionell
medienwelt auf dem sie immer häufiger
stoßen
[Musik]
ende 2001 wurde eric schmidt google
geschäftsführer
page übernahmen produkt und bringen die
technologie-sparte die beiden gründer
teilten sich immer noch ein büro ihre
geister sind miteinander verschmolzen
sie wissen was der andere sagen will
sind füreinander da es gibt keine
spannungen zwischen ihm das ist eine
ihrer großen stärken
mit eric schmidt setzte google sein
spektakuläres wachstum fort während die
rivalen langsam verbleichen
die suchmaschine war mit drei milliarden
webseiten verbindlich und ging eine
partnerschaft mit aol ein die ihnen 34
millionen neuer kunden brachte
wenn man so ein unglaublich profitables
unternehmen haben wie kommt man ins
nächste level woher sollte das benötigte
kapital wachstum kommen
die lösung es war an der zeit für google
an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen
sie waren unkonventionell also
beschlossen sie einen börsengang
hinzulegen den wall street so noch nicht
gesehen hatte sie legten den preis über
eine option fest um den größtmöglichen
wert aus der aktie haus zu holen
der kurs schloss am 19 august 2004 bei
knapp über 100 dollar pro aktie womit
das unternehmen mehr als 23 milliarden
dollar wert war die beiden gründer
wurden milliardäre
gewalt expandierte das unternehmen mit
google maps google news und google
mit idealismus und kühnen ideen haben
sie ihren ruf aufgebaut stolpert dann
aber über ihren kostenlosen e mail
google mail oder ein tolles aber
schlecht eingeführtes produkt
werbeanzeigen die sich direkt auf
persönliche e mails bezogen riesen bei
benutzern die alarmglocken schrillen als
diese leute diese anzeigen zum ersten
mal sahen waren sich schockiert sie
dachten wie können die so zielgerichtet
sein ich lese eine mail über den urlaub
eines freundes auf hawaii und bekomme
anzeigen über hawaii schnüffelt da
jemand in mein mails die bedenken lösten
eine noch viel grundlegendere diskussion
über datenschutz und vertrauen
wissen sie wie google die informationen
verwendet die es über sie sammelt all
die web suchen der letzten jahre die e
mails die ich geschrieben habe
möglicherweise informationen über meine
gesundheit über bücher die ich lese
darüber wohin ich gehe weil ich es in
google maps eingeben in gewisser weise
sind sie der big brother über den wir
gesprochen haben
der big brother stellte seine
philosophie des nicht bösartig science
auf die probe
2006 einigte sich google mit china auf
den zugang zu seinen 400 millionen
internet
unter der bedingung dass sie verbotene
themen von tieren
verbringen sohn russischer einwanderer
eine beunruhigende entscheidung bei
einem freitags treffen von google sprach
sergej mit leidenschaft über das
aufwachsen in der sowjetunion und wie
seine eltern buchstäblich geflohen sind
und nach amerika zu kommen und was das
für ihn bedeutet sie haben mit allen
mitarbeitern darüber gesprochen musste
schwer schlucken aber bei google haben
alle gesagt das ist der größte
verbraucher mag der welt wir müssen da
rein
google stimmte chinas forderungen zu
ich weiß es gab eine menge kontroversen
darüber und wir mussten ziemlich viel
zensieren aber es wurde immer weniger
und unsere lokalen konkurrenten dort
haben auch immer weniger zensiert also
hat unsere teilnahme auch etwas bewegt
aber
trotzdem ging es dann irgendwie bergab
google entdeckte einen cyberangriff auf
seine systeme
das beunruhigende für mich ist dass wir
entdeckt haben welche motivation
dahinter steckt nämlich an gmail konten
zu kommen vor allem von chinesischen
menschenrechtsaktivisten
google zog den stecker und leitete die
nutzer auf eine ungefilterte seite in
hongkong die nicht der zensur unterlag
begann als plattform für ein videos und
entwickelte sich bald zu einer der
weltweit führenden suchmaschinen im juni
2006 luden benutzer täglich
65.000 videos hoch und google wollte da
rein
sie kauften youtube für 1,65 milliarden
dollar in google aktien
heute haben wir spannende neuigkeiten
für euch wurden von google ja danke
2006 erkannte google chef eric schmidt
das unternehmen auch in die welt der
mobiltelefone einsteigen muss so hat er
um wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben
tatsächlich hatten sie ein jahr zuvor
stillschweigend ein start-up gekauft
android ein kleines unternehmen
es gibt so viel mehr handys als computer
die leute surfen immer mehr über sein
die im internet am ende sollte es sich
ausgleichen aber das wird auch wieder
viele jahre dauern es hat nicht lange
gedauert der phänomenale erfolg von
apple mit dem iphone brachte die
unternehmen 2007 auf kollisionskurs
monate später kündigte brennen page das
android-betriebssystem für sie
der einstieg ins telefongeschäft brachte
ihr langjähriges idol steve jobs gegen
sie aus er beschuldigte sie das iphone
töten
auf einer google entwicklerkonferenz im
mai 2010 setzte sich der vize präsident
der technikabteilung mit apple
auseinander
google musste handeln
sonst würde es in zukunft nur einen mann
ein unternehmen ein gerät einem
betreiber geben
so einer zukunft wollten wir nicht
und google kämpft noch mit einem anderen
giganten an der technologie welt sie
stoßen auf so viele arten mit microsoft
zusammen sie haben einen browser chrome
microsoft hat einen internet explorer
war auch unternehmen die mit
online-versionen von text und tabellen
software handelten dinge die direkt auf
microsofts halsschlagader zielten
microsoft feuerte mit seiner eigenen
suchmaschine bing zurück in die im
frühjahr 2009 an dem starken darf ich
fragen was du von bego erhälst magst du
es
ich denke sind sie ein benutzer
ja nein nein ich benutze alle
suchmaschinen ich denke dass zwingen uns
daran erinnert dass die internetsuche
einen sehr umkämpfter markt ist
dem boden will ironischerweise schutz
weil sich damit der vorwurf einem
monopol zu sein erledigt
bill gates sagte dieser konkurrent ist
uns von allen am nächsten die sind
genauso hungrig und rücksichtslos er hat
dieses wort nicht benutzt aber ich tu's
sie laufen gefahr sich viele feinde zum
beiden gründer haben sich immer für
edelmänner gehalten sie dachten das was
sie tun ist gut für die welt
sie haben es genossen sich wie die
underdogs zu fühlen microsoft als den
bösen
aber jetzt merken sie dass manche leute
sie für die bösen halten
ihr eigenes logo in don't be evil wurde
plötzlich gegen sie verwendet
[Musik]
ziel informationen zu organisieren
schlug eine neue richtung ein mit einem
ambitionierten feature namens
mit dem ziel jedes viertel der welt zu
fotografieren
von normalen straßen bildern/s
hin zu außergewöhnlichen ansichten der
antarktis
allerdings wurden dafür auch nutzer
informationen aus ungesicherten
wlan-netzen verwertet eine verletzung
der privatsphäre
google gab den fehler zu und musste
daher nicht
das unternehmen kämpfte darum wo
vielfältiger zu werden und sah sich
einem aggressiven neuen herausforderer
gegenüber mark zuckerberg eine milliarde
facebook-nutzer und hosten wertvolle
informationen die für die suchmaschine
von google um sich
informationen die alle werbetreibenden
haben
bisher hatte google mit sozialen
netzwerken keinen erfolg
aber den gründern ist bewusst dass ihr
unternehmen mit den sich ändernden
nutzergewohnheiten mithalten
[Musik]
im januar 2011 gab eric schmidt
überraschend bekannt dass google seine
verwaltungsstruktur vereinfacht und dass
larry page bereit sei ihn als
mitbegründer sergey brin konzentrierte
sich auf neue produkte schmidt hatte
keine tägliche aufsicht durch erwachsene
männer
innerhalb von 14 jahren wuchs google von
start up zum technologieriesen und
erzielte 2012 einen umsatz von 50
milliarden dollar
larry page und sergey brin waren
inzwischen verheiratet
page nahm im dezember 2007 promovierte
stanford bio informatikerin lose hin
dass auf der insel von richard
branson war auch sein trauzeuge drin
heiratete auf den bahamas die
biotechnologie spezialistin android ski
und sein partner larry page stand ihm
zur seite beide haben zwei kinder
google.org der gemeinnützige zweig des
unternehmens hat über 100 millionen
dollar an verschiedene organisationen
gespendet von sauberer energie bis hin
zu globaler gesundheit larry page und
sergey brin haben die art wie wir
informationen erhalten verändert
es war eine großartige erfahrung für
mich sehen diesen zwölf jahren die ich
sie kenne wachsen zu sehen ich bin sehr
stolz auf das was sie erreicht haben
larian sergej hatten schon immer diese
art von respektlosigkeit als teil ihrer
haltung die sie so kreativ gemacht hat
ich denke google zieht leute an die sich
kümmern um die nutzer ihre mitmenschen
um den planeten die einfach nicht warum
sitzen wollen sie haben ein unternehmen
aufgebaut das die welt absolut verändert
hat
[Musik]
mark zuckerberg war ein harvard neuling
mit einer begabung fürs programmieren
weniger als ein jahrzehnt später als
lehrer multimilliardär mit dem baby
gesicht bau der mit dem präsident nicht
zusammen
und ich habe mark dazu gebracht hat und
krawatte zu tragen
ich glaube die meisten leute haben die
größe von facebook noch nicht wirklich
verstanden und wie schnell es gewachsen
ist das ziel ist offensichtlich eine
allgegenwart mark zuckerberg möchte dass
alle diesen service nutzen er das
wohnheim projekt zum größten globalen
dorf des index die seite hat
mittlerweile über 900 millionen nutzer
man kann nicht unterschätzen wie
getrieben sagte berg ist er ist genauso
visionär steve jobs
kürzlich als genauso einflussreich
erweisen wie bill gates trotz des
erfolgs lieferte sich sachsenburg
erbitterte kämpfe
er wollte sein eigenes ding
kontrollieren und wenn er gegen jemanden
vorgeht wenn sie den vermissten wir
haben drei monate mit marc gearbeitet
und wurden hier das licht geführt wir
hatten keine ahnung dass er an einem
konkurrenzprodukt arbeit er hat einen
totalen krieg gegen seine größten
konkurrenten
die beziehungen zwischen facebook und
google ist ziemlich einfach sie mögen
sich einfach nicht und zuckerberg geriet
unter beschuss weil er die grenzen der
privatsphäre nutzer haben weniger
kontrolle über private informationen sie
wissen nicht genau wie ihre infos
weitergegeben werden handelt nicht nur
mit einem stück technik er handelt mit
menschen und ihrem verhalten und das
ohne viel darüber nachzudenken
sie haben diese riesige datenbank mit
informationen über uns angehäuft weil
wir ihnen vertraut haben die frage ist
also sollen wir ihnen weiter vertrauen
[Musik]
ich glaube unser ziel war keine online
community sondern eine art spiegel der
echten gemeinschaft den wirklichen leben
existiert mona zuckerberg wir denken wir
kennen ihn beide sein leben im oscar
prämierten film the social network
gesehen das porträt war schonungslos
einen super nerd halsabschneider
brillant aber sozial ich verstehe nicht
welchem teil aber stimmte das auch immer
freunde er ist ein ziemlich sozialer typ
ich glaube das letzte mal habe ich 879
freunde auf facebook an
das hier ist der wahre mark zuckerberg
2005 in facebooks ernster zentrale von
jungen filmemachern getroffen
wir haben drei
millionen nutzer und seit wann gibt es
facebook nicht so lange
währen zuckerberg die privatsphäre der
nutzer ausreizt entschied er sich gegen
die teilnahme an unserem programm
2004 gründete er facebook im alter von
19 jahren mit facebook inzwischen hat
der 28-jährige ein geschätztes vermögen
von 15 5 milliarden dollar angehäuft
max mission war von anfang an menschen
zu verbinden sie basierte auf diese
theorie dass die welt ein besserer ort
wäre wenn sie stärker verbunden wäre
aber es gibt viele überraschungen wenn
man wirklich tief in die geschichte von
facebook eintaucht die größte ist die
eigenwillige persönlichkeit von mark
zuckerberg
die tiefe seiner überzeugungen
[Musik]
1984 geboren wuchs er in jobs terry am
hudson aus in einer wohnsiedlung
nördlich von new york city david
kirkpatrick recherchierte zwei jahre
lang für ein buch über sascha burg und
facebook mit dem titel the facebook
effect er stammt aus einer unglaublichen
unterstützenden familie in der er der
einzige sohn war er hat drei schwestern
also war er eine art drin ich glaube
seine eltern haben ihn sogar den prinzen
genannt und er wurde dementsprechend
behandelt er ist ein typ ohne probleme
mit dem selbstvertrauen computer talent
von anfang an brachte sich sascha bert
die komplizierte computersprache sieglos
platz in der neunten klasse entwickelte
er eine digitale version des brettspiels
risiko
antonio vargas interviewte zuckerberg
für sein new yorker magazin profil
tatsächlich angewandt sagt ned
geschaffen hernes instant messaging
system für die familie damit wie
computer miteinander reden konnten
so ein kind gewesen
als er seine highschool satt hatte
beschloss er auf die exit school zu
gehen wirklich weil er einfach mehr
herausforderungen wollte in der
exklusiven exeter erstellten zuckerberg
und sein freund adam die angelo eine
musik website
sie sollte so sein dass sie deine
vorlieben erkennt und sie war sehr
beliebt noch bevor er mit facebook
anfiel
er lehnte angebote von microsoft und
anderen ups in apps für weit über eine
million dollar zu verkaufen
viele namhafte unternehmen wollten ihn
direkt aus exeter rekrutieren sie eine
tech version eines pollstar athleten
beginn war zuckerberg war unbeeindruckt
und entschied sich 2002 statt dessen für
harvard
wo ist nicht lange dauert es erste pläne
bekam zuckerberg hatte sich in die
computer der uni und bilder von schülern
zusammen nico das carls
stellvertretender redakteur bei business
insider dot com liegen so ein bisschen
am ingolstädter ist gerade in seinem
ersten jahr in harvard etwas erfunden
das facemash als eine art horw toren
noch für die uni und dann führte die
seite eine ganze liste von harvard
studenten welche die attraktivste waren
nach schönheit
war irgendwie ein bisschen eklig ist
verweigerte die leute offensichtlich
fühlten sie sich verspottet oder
bloßgestellt
es war eine der ersten großen
erfahrungen die mag mit
datenschutzproblemen macht
zuckerberg schloss die seit die harvard
verwaltung klagte ihn wegen
sicherheitsverletzung verletzung von
urheberrechten und verletzung der
privatsphäre
aber facemash war zu dem zeitpunkt schon
einen campus sensation zuckerberg hatte
gleich in die zeit als er ärger mit
dieser fiesen webb hatte bekam baute er
ein anderes dieses tool das super
beliebt war
ich kann mir vorstellen dass ein paar
schlaflose nächte hatte und sich sorgen
machte wie schlimm diese sache werden
würde aber erleichtert als alles vorbei
war und war aber auch unglaublich
neugierig was er als nächstes machen
könnte wenn du ein genie mit genialen
freundin bist und in irgend einem
schlafsaal sitzt sieht die welt wie ein
großer glücklicher ort aus wenn er in
diese datenbank kommst die welt der
datenbanken veränderte sich damals
rasant
breton ist senior writer bei der
bloomberg businessweek das internet war
2004 eine ganz andere welt ein fenster
sieht man dass ein soziales netzwerk
technisch funktionieren die seite hängt
sich immer auch unzuverlässig nochmals
voll mit werbung
an der harvard lernte zuckerberg den
schüler und zukünftigen geschäftspartner
ist einer der wenigen die herrin über
die anfänge von facebook interviewt
haben
traf mark zuckerberg bei einer jüdischen
bruderschaft
war nicht wirklich lustig war eine etwas
seltsame soziale umgebung nicht
schlechte partys meistens nur jungs also
trafen sich überall nur einmal in dieser
szene und sie wurden ziemlich schnell
freunde weil sie beide eine art
außenseiter waren
aufmerksam
eine idee die ich ende 2002 als junior
im college
die drei bastelten seit fast einem jahr
an der seite zwei ihrer programmierbaren
abgesprungen und sie brauchten dringend
einen neuen partner
wir sind keine computer programmierer
von beruf oder so wir brauchten einen
echten programmierer um das wir uns zu
schreiben
und wir dachten mag wäre dieser typ also
gingen sie auf sascha bertow gebirge
er war begeistert aufgeregt und seine
augen strahlten
wo erst dann geschah löste einen
erbitterten streit darüber aus wie
facebook eigentlich entstanden war die
details werden in e mails zwischen
zuckerberg und dem havag connect
zu beginn war zuckerberg noch als
eigentlich ich habe eure sachen gelesen
und ich denke die umsetzung sollte nicht
allzu lange dauern sie können darüber
reden wenn ich morgen abend alles
hochgefahren habe dann fing zuckerberg
ami das projekt zu verzögern der täter
dezember entschuldigt dass ich nicht
erreichbar war ich habe gerade euere
verpassten anrufe gesehen ich habe an
einem problem gearbeitet zehnter
dezember die woche war ziemlich stressig
konnte noch nicht wirklich an der seite
arbeiten oder darüber nachdenken
zuckerberg zögerte weil er damit
beschäftigt war an einer ähnlichen
social network seite zu arbeiten die auf
dem studenten verzeichnis von harvard
basierte facebook er und service haben
sich zusammen um sie zu finanzieren
kam zu ihm und sagte was du investierst
1000 dollar
es gab keine verträge das waren wirklich
nur zwei kinder in einem schlafsaal
interviewte mehr als ein dutzend leuten
die an der gründung und facebook
beteiligt war und er entdeckte sofort
nachrichten die zuckerberg am semmering
geschrieben laut business insider deuten
die nachrichten an dass zuckerberg die
winklevoss-zwillinge bewusst in die irre
die interregio westwind er schrieb dinge
wie guck dir diese seite an harvard
connection hh wir haben einen fehler
gemacht die haben mich gebeten dass für
sie zu machen aber ich arbeite an meinem
eigenen facebook wir hatten immer den
eindruck dass markt an harvard
connection dot com arbeitet
ihm dass er das nicht tut oder nicht tun
wollte oder an etwas identischem
arbeitete auf der seite
facebook als er sich das letzte mal mit
den winklevoss brüdern traf begriff er
dass er ihn wohl sagen sollte dass er an
einem konkurrenzprodukt saß er hat mit
freunden darüber gesprochen hätte sagte
er weißt du was ich mache ich lass sie
abblitzen ich würde sie ab
februar 2004 als er eigentlich ihre
seite fertig stellen sollte brachte
sascha berg mit seinen freunden
stattdessen
facebook
erfuhren war genauso wie fast alle
anderen
es hat uns komplett überrumpelt damit
haben wir nicht gerechnet
hat wollte die kontrolle über sein
eigenes projekt haben er sah dass sie
etwas cooles vor hatten die
winklevoss-brüder aber er sagt dass er
etwas kühleres machen konnten dagegen
vorgeht
soziales netzwerk facebook sorgte von
anfang an für kontroversen nur wenige
tage nach dem start im februar 2004
schickten ihm die winklevoss zwillinge
und diana ranger eine
unterlassungsaufforderung
uns gesagt klagten wir gegen mark
zuckerberg wegen betrugs
ungerechtfertigter bereicherung und
vertragsbruchs
ein separates unternehmen für uns
verwenden nicht den gleichen
worten später einen
sie verloren vor einem bundesgericht
soll dieser vergleich bitte jetzt 200
millionen dollar wert sein doch keines
dieser juristischen gerangel bremst es
unglaubliche dynamik von facebook oder
facebook zu diesem zeitpunkt dachten
meine mitbewohner das ist ziemlich cool
ich lasse das wurde auch an anderen
schulen funktionieren also haben wir es
nicht
und innerhalb von wenigen wochen hatten
die tausende von nutzern und wir sagt
dann lass uns einfach mal gucken in wie
vielen schwulen wie die seite noch so
schnell wie möglich starten können zu
diesem zeitpunkt begannen sie sich mit
risikokapitalgebern und größeren
werbetreibenden zu treffen es war
eigentlich alles
sie bekamen einen ziemlich früh indien
mit visa und sie hatten einen deal mit
american express
sie hatten eine reihe von
werbetreibenden zu planen und gingen
dann begannen plattenfirmen sich zu
interessieren und sie erzielten ziemlich
gute einnahmen aus der musikindustrie
auf einer reise nach new york
zuckerberg und sein partner eduardo
saverin mit dem 24-jährigen mitbegründer
von netzwerken zu abend essen ein
gestandener unternehmer und ein wirklich
kreative außergewöhnlich interessanter
mensch der es ins netzwerk in silicon
valley geschafft hatte so dass man
einfach sterben könnte
parker war für zuckerberg und vorbild
romo hartner saverin sei nicht
einverstanden hallo hier von anfang an
nicht viel von chong jena dachte schon
sein quacksalber sie bräuchten spuckt
große töne lebe aber dass im see sein
und sei aus zwei firmen aus geschmissen
werden
im sommer 2004 verließ sack
an der ostküste
wir sind diesen sommer nach palo alto
gekommen um abzuheben palo alto ist so
ein mythischer ort wo alles tat ab und
wir haben zu beginn des jahres den start
150 weiteren schulen
durch den wechsel nach palo alto -
wirklich in die petrischale der
unternehmen kik vor allem für neue
technologien zuckerberg und seine
freunde zogen in ein großes fachwerkhaus
mit schwimmbad und er traf wieder auf
sean parker er später sascha brox
mitbewohner
jeweils er war ein aufseher für
erwachsene diese gibt er ihm gezeigt hat
wie die dinge im silicon valley laufen
ihnen gezeigt wie man investoren trifft
wie man mit ihm verhandelt
man
hat mir geschichten von all den jungs
erzählt die spätnachts am esstisch herum
programmieren und chicken mcnuggets und
müsli essen
das wirklich schon parker bringt sie zu
den anderen coolen silicon valley
hotspot und währenddessen wächst die
website astronomischen ich meine im
dezember dieses jahres hatten sie eine
eigene junge mitglieder paar
kaká hat zuckerberg in dieser zeit viele
ratschläge gegeben war er sich zu herzen
sein anderen sagte du musst der gründer
dieser sache sein du musst immer der ceo
sei was du kannst das nicht an
investoren abgeben
und mag konnte einige sehr wichtige
investitionsabkommen aushandeln die zwei
dinge bewirken
sie gaben ihnen genügend mittel um die
klügsten ingenieure der branche
einzustellen und zweitens er konnte die
mehrheit am unternehmen behalten
bedarf die spannungen mit seinem
ursprünglichen partner eduardo saverin
der an der ostküste geblieben waren
wurden immer größer
er fühlte sich als kaufmännischer leiter
des unternehmens wurde aber nicht mehr
so behandelt hat meetings in ganz
kalifornien ignoriert
aufmerksamkeit und marc und schon sieht
in einer weg das unternehmen
hatte eine million aktive nutzer und
universitäten im ganzen land und es
begann viel geld zufließen
der neue präsident von facebook stellte
zuckerberg dem silicon valley angel
investor peter thiel vor der 500.000
dollar in das unternehmen steckte im
frühjahr 2005 bot die venture capital
gesellschaft excel partners zuckerberg
12,7 millionen dollar für eine 11
sie wollten überhaupt nicht viel
kontrolle kontrolliert er jetzt drei von
fünf vorstand sitzen
besaß ist eine bizarre und beispiellose
situation
wenn eine person die absolute
diktatorische kontrolle über die
aufstellung und leitung eines zunehmend
riesigen unternehmens hat
die excel investition brachte facebook
über nacht eine bewertung von 100
millionen dollar
mit dem öffentlichen profil von facebook
wuchs auch sascha brox machten tro
dieses mal wurde sean parker verdrängt
im august 2005 wurde er wegen des
verdachts des kokainbesitzes
erforschen obwohl er nicht offiziell
angeklagt und sofort freigelassen wurde
führte dies zu seinem sofortigen
rücktritt
war der wichtigste repräsentant des
unternehmens aber man war der meinung
dass jemand der mit drogen zu tun hatte
nicht der richtige typ war um facebook
nach außen zu vertreten also stimmte
mark widerstrebend seiner entlassung zu
wuchs mit bemerkenswerter
geschwindigkeit und zuckerberg verlegte
das unternehmen von seiner studentenbude
mit dem pool in einen größeren und
konventionelleren raum in der innenstadt
von palo alto
aber wie college atmosphäre liebt
dieselbe
dass die kultur freundlich und die
läuterung in sachen verwaltung des
ganzen prozesses
nichts ich habe keine ahnung was ich tue
auch ihre mitarbeitergespräche waren
anders chris kelly wurde in der neuen
position des chief privacy officers
eingestellt um sich mit denen zunehmend
schwierigen datenschutz themen bei
facebook zu befassen zu einer zeit als
das gesamte unternehmen nur ein paar
dutzend mitarbeiter
als ich mag zum ersten mal traf
kletterten wir durch das fenster auf
start und führten unser interview auf
dem dach eines weltverbesserung
was bisher passiert war und wohin er die
firma 40 leute
entschlossen die ungewöhnlich kreative
kultur von facebook zu erhalten waren
programmieren echte eine möglichkeit das
zu tun wir haben diese meetings in der
firma wo alle zusammen kommen und
einfach zu trainieren die ganze nacht
was bahn und die einzige regel ist dass
man bei den treffen nicht an dem aber im
rat ansonsten
waren eines der kreativsten dinge die
man sich in einem unternehmen vorstellen
konnte da kommen diese unglaublich
talentierten ingenieure zusammen und
sagen wir bleiben die ganze nacht wir
programmieren einfach wir suchen uns ein
projekt aus und machen
das ist toll macht darf wir machen und
prototypen daraus dann gibt's ein krieg
und wir sehen wer gewinnt
vom aus marktsicht entstehen auf diese
weise gute ideen schnell und effizient
lässt kabel sehr gute ideen sonntag aber
führte etwas ein dass facebook einen
plötzlichen und dramatischen schub gast
es ermöglichte den leuten sich und ihre
freunde auf fotos zu identifizieren oder
zu markieren
das war eine riesige umstellung das
führte zu einer massiven neuen nutzung
von
facebook fotos waren sehr schnell der
bei weitem am meisten genutzte teil von
facebook facebook und der größte
wachstumstreiber
dieses wachstum ging in eine richtung
weiter nach oben laut facebook internem
tracking wuchs die zahl der nutzer in
weniger als zwei jahren auf 5,5
millionen
mediengiganten kematen an die tür
2006 machte yahoo dem 22-jährigen
zuckerberg ein außergewöhnliches angebot
ein bei auch für eine milliarde dollar
dort
noch außergewöhnlicher zuckerberg lehnte
ab
wenn sie eltern von jemandem in max
alter sind gucken sie sich die yahoo
entscheidung an und denken warum hast du
das geld nicht genommen
es ging nie um geld wenn es so wäre wäre
es einfach aus verkauft haben ich habe
einfach das gefühl das ist uns nicht
dabei helfen wurde facebook zu dem zu
machen was wir uns vorstellen
2006 lehnte mark zuckerberg einen
milliardenschweren pitch von yahoo als
mtv den einsatz noch hören
was die eu von mtv networks mark hätte
mir noch mark hatte mich auf einen
spaziergang durch palo alto mitgenommen
und mir seine wohnung gezeigt
dann gingen wir mittags und ich sagte
ihm dass wir bereit wären bis zu
anderthalb milliarden dollar zu zahlen
meine antwort war ist ich denke wir sind
viel mehr wert und außerdem hast du
meine wohnung gesehen drittel geld
brauche ich mit der parade money er
vielleicht habe ich nie wieder eine so
gute idee
ich will nicht wirklich
innere unruhen keine frage es gab viele
leute die verkaufen wollten uns markt
beschloss einfach diese angebote
abzulehnen
zuckerberg war noch nicht bereit zu
verkaufen weil er einige ideen hatte von
denen er dachte dass sie facebook noch
bekannter machen würden skoll eine von
ihnen hieß newsfeed eine art
echtzeitnachrichten uns darüber was die
nutzer gerade tun
newsfeed ist was jemand gerade tut oder
was apostel sind mit der welt verbindet
in der erlebt also etwas das eine
zeitung tut es ist eine lebendige
atmende zeitung von menschen um dich
herum aber viele facebook-nutzer dachten
dass diese zeitung zu viele
informationen verschickt und ihre
privatsphäre verletzt
750000 von demenz starteten einen online
protest zu sagen dass es unpopulär war
es eine dramatische untertreibung sie
wurden im büro belagert sie konnten
nicht gehört sie waren von reportern der
nutzer schlossen sich den studenten
gegen die facebook newsfeed gruppe an
so aber musste sich entschuldigen
er hat seine entschuldigung selbst
geschrieben es war wahrscheinlich eine
gute lernerfahrung als facebook einige
der datenschutz einstellungen ändern es
war eine überschreitung ich glaube er
nimmt das ernst aber ich glaube dass er
bereit ist weiter zu gehen um ein
produkt herzustellen dass er herstellen
möchte
die entschuldigung war keine
kapitulation
zuckerberg war sich sicher dass sich die
nutzer an diese neue art des teilens
gewöhnen würden und er behielt recht
achtung nach der optimierung des
newsweek wurde es zu einem der
beliebtesten elemente
ein erstes treffen mit marc war zufällig
zwei tage nach dem was passiert war und
ich kann ihnen sagen obwohl seine
mitglieder in auf rohwaren war er nicht
im geringsten
er hatte volles vertrauen dass alles gut
gehen würde
zuckerberg entschied dass es an der zeit
sei facebook über die grenzen hinaus zu
führen und der breiten öffentlichkeit
vorzustellen
die resonanz war die mitgliederzahl
verdoppelt und stieg bis 2006 auf 12
millionen
zuckerberg veränderte facebook erneut
radikal ist beginnen weil es der 23
jährige programmierer aus aller welt
einluden apps zu entwickeln du wirst zu
facebook es war ein weiterer wendepunkt
der facebook von einer abgeschotteten
informationswelt zu einer plattform
ausbaute
es war wie im goldrausch geöffnet diese
wundervolle plattformen und alle
möglichen entwickler kommen mit einem
möglichen ideen von video sharing über
spiele bis hin zu dem die linken sich in
ballerinas oder nilpferde verwandeln und
einfach jeder art von lustigen sachen
plattform oder betriebssystem
unternehmen machen immer das beste
microsoft hatte diese allgegenwärtige
und raus plattform und all diese anderen
firmen haben programme für windows
geschwungen facebook versucht wirklich
sicher selbst zu erschaffen und
2007 brachte sich microsoft selbst
diesmal mit einem deal den sack am berg
nicht ablehnen konnte und zum ersten mal
bekam die welt einen eindruck davon
leute gewöhnen sich daran dass jeder
eine milliarde dollar für facebook
bezahlen würde microsoft kommt und zahl
250 millionen dollar für 1,6 prozent des
unternehmens
das unternehmen wurde damit auf 15
milliarden dollar geschätzt das hat
facebook zu einer sache gemacht über den
alle redeten das 15 milliarden dollar
unternehmen da war für 1 15 milliarden
dollar unternehmen machte facebook nur
magere 30 millionen dollar gewinn
um dem abzuhelfen kündigte zuckerberg
ein umfassendes neues wertesystem ein
teil davon ermöglicht es unternehmen im
herbst 2007 ihre eigenen facebook seiten
einzurichten und mit social es
lou kerner beschäftigt sich mit social
media und besitzt anteile an facebook
social apps auf facebook sind anzeigen
in denen deine freunde meckereien sagen
dass sie virgin america mögen und es
überrascht nicht dass wenn man sie ist
das deine freunde ein produkt mögen das
duo ja auch diese anzeige klickt und so
waren diese social ads von anfang an
sehr erfolgreich beenden aber ein
anderer teil des neuen werbe plans von
facebook bb king geht den nutzern weit
mehr als sie wollten und sie ließen
zuckerberg davon wissen
hat viele fehler gemacht bis der nächste
wirklich große fehler war
du gehst auf eine e commerce seite eines
dritten täters in kauf und wenn du nicht
schnellgang gebiss geht es zurück und
für uns alle deine freunde darüber
informieren du gerade einem diamant
verlobungsring gekauft es gab den großen
aufschrei dass facebook weihnachten
ruiniert hat weil plötzlich alle
einkäufe in ihr gesamtes netzwerk
übertragen wurden
wirklich eine wahl versucht das zu
verteidigen es dauerte ein bisschen bis
er erkannte wie falsch es war
dezember 2007 entschuldigte sich
zuckerberg er hatte es wieder mal
übertrieben gern aber wie bei früheren
fehlern würde es nicht wirklich
war einfach zu beliebt und es dauerte
nicht lange bis hamburg die
datenschutzbestimmungen des netzwerks
mehr als vier jahre seit der gründung
von facebook fühlte sich zuckerberg in
der öffentlichkeit immer noch zu
verkaufen sie
keins von den gerüchten das war oder
das ist mir sehr unangenehm bis 2009
kursierten gerüchte dass facebook börse
gehen
stattdessen nahm zuckerberg geld von
einem neuen investor
yuri milner geschäftsführer der
russischen internet investmentfirma
digital sky technologies
er bot einen 200 millionen dollar für
nur 19 prozent des unternehmens an
geschäfte dieser größenordnung sind nie
einfach ist gleich viel hin und her dass
der bei diesem deal ging es um die
vision die wir teilchen wie groß dieses
unternehmen werden kann
bildungsinvestitionen ermöglichte es
facebook weiter zu expandieren die
entwicklung des unternehmens fest in den
händen des gründers lacaba kloster in
der facebook werbung liegt der schlüssel
für weitere
glaubte jahre lang in einer
einzigartigen position sei
selbst mit den besten werbesystem die es
geht gibt es nur schätzungen geschlecht
alter oder interessen einer person
facebook wissen wir genau welches
geschlecht sie hat genau und genau
market ein unternehmen des aktien- und
privat gehaltene unternehmen vermittelt
die noch nicht am öffentlichen markt
gehandelt werden
aus sicht der werbetreibenden so
begehrenswert macht ist dass sie wie
kein anderer informationen über ihre
nutzer sagen kann das lustige ist dass
die nutzer das nicht wirklich als daten
kraft sind sie selbst es sind ihre
informationen es ist wir leben das sie
doch veröffentlichen
[Musik]
dieses heiligen grabes brachte sascha
berg erneut in schwierigkeiten in der
zimmer 2009 überarbeitete er die
datenschutz einstellungen für die damals
350 millionen facebook wenn die nutzer
ihre einstellungen nicht einzeln wieder
herstellten darum private informationen
jetzt für alle im internet
viele leute haben diese vorgabe einfach
übernommen und unabsichtlich zugelassen
dass ihre informationen veröffentlicht
werden und viele datenschützer glauben
dass sie das nicht erklärt oder
ausreichend offengelegt haben
ein feuersturm an beschwerden im sängern
und verbraucherverbänden zuckerberg
erneut zum rückzieher und löste im
kongress besorgnis aus wir sind heute
hier um den cio von facebook mark
zuckerberg aufzufordern die neue
richtlinie so schnell wie möglich zu
überdenken wir sind der meinung dass
facebook die richtlinien ändern sollte
damit die nutzer im voraus wissen was
passiert
das feuer noch weiter am instant
messages business insider
veröffentlichte nachrichten in denen ein
freund sascha berg polizei in der fragt
habe warum die leute ihre e mails mit
ihm teilten seine antwort
ich habe ihm direkt danach gefragt
weniger als einen monat später wurde er
in einem denkwürdig peinlichen interview
bei der all things digital konferenz
gegrillt haben sie das gefühl die
privatsphäre anderer zu verletzen
wir haben beim aufbau viel gelernt
es gab echte wendepunkte
er nicht damals gewusst hätte was ich
heute weiß dann hätte ich die fehler
wohl nicht gemacht aber ich kann mich
zurück in die vergangenheit kann nur das
tun was wir für richtig halten
jeder der jemals daran gezweifelt hat
worum es bei facebook geht aber seine
integrität in frage stellen wollte kann
sich immer wieder darauf berufen oder
ich kann diesen kerl nicht trauen das
wird unsere kontrolle über ihn sein
solange er ceo bleibt und das
unternehmen leitet es wird heißen bist
nicht dieser typ weise uns das nicht
[Musik]
glaubt beim datenschutz gezielt an die
grenze
muss in den meisten situationen in denen
ein unternehmen etwas unpopuläres tut
gibt es einen rückschlag und sie
verlieren die fähigkeit etwas zu tun
aber im fall von facebook haben wir
etwas das ich bloß portman oder sie zwei
schritte nach vorne machen es gibt eine
öffentliche reaktion sie täten nur einen
kleinen schritt zurück und so können
diesen im laufe der zeit immer mehr
profile öffnung
[Musik]
monat ist der meinung dass man bei der
arbeit kein anderer mensch sein sollte
als auf der bowlingbahn im bett oder in
der schule er findet dass man in all
diesen umgebungen gleich sein sollte ist
für viele ältere menschen eine sehr
radikale ansichten
25 jahre alt wurde war er so bekannt
reich mächtig
ihn und die gründung von
diese geschichte begann für mich mit
einer e mail die ich aus heiterem himmel
bekannt
er wollte seine geschichte erzählt er
hatte mit mark zuckerberg facebook
gegründet und sagte er sei aus der firma
rausgeschmissen worden fühlte sich
betrogen und geräten
gegen seinen ehemaligen hawass
klassenkameraden eingereicht hatte
mit ihm sprach sie haben sich dann im
wesentlichen einig niemand weiß genau
was passiert ist aber ich habe gehört
dass er 15 von facebook hat und eine
vereinbarung unterzeichnen musste dass
er nie wieder mit benders wegbricht
brother hat er schon genug stoppte sein
mein vorschlag line internet
durchgesehen
scott rudin hat es gesehen und zog im
boot und sofort in das drehbuch zu
schreiben
die vorab werbung für den film schien
zuckerberg zu einer pr-offensive zu
drängen
der eigentlich so schüchterne zuckerberg
war plötzlich überall wenn man etwas
großartiges macht interessiert dass die
leute das ist den leuten egal was jemand
in einem film über diese 2010 gab er
oprah winfrey eine führung durch sein
haus und kündigte eine 100 millionen
dollar spende an schulen in newark new
jersey
100 millionen
[Applaus]
2010 kam der film das soziale netzwerk
die leute wollen ins internet gehen und
ihre freunde schicken warum also nicht
eine website bauen wie das bietet die
spreche davon die gesamte soziale
erfahrung der uni zu nutzen und sie
online zu stellen zuckerberg beschwerte
sich war sein porträt auf dem bildschirm
als rücksichtsloser sozial behinderter
powervr ikone freunde er sagte es gebe
sachliche fehler im drehbuch
das wäre der grund facebook zu machen
dass sich mädchen treffen will oder in
eine soziale einrichtung einsteigen will
aber die leute die mich kennen wissen
ich bin mit demselben mädchen zusammen
seit ich mit facebook angefangen habe
sie können sich einfach nicht mit der
vorstellung auseinandersetzen dass
jemand etwas bauen könnte weil einfach
gerne dinge baut
[Applaus]
obwohl er anfang sagte er würde sich den
film nicht ansehen kam zuckerberg am
ende mit seiner gesamten belegschaft
jemals den film gesehen dass soziale
netwerke
interessant
das soziale netzwerk gewann einen golden
globe für das beste drama
dass tunesien jetzt ägypten
was kommt als nächstes
aber für immer mehr menschen auf der
ganzen welt war facebook
ist beeinflusst wird das wirkliche leben
ende 2010 gingen demonstranten in
tunesien und später in ägypten auf die
straße um gegen die repressiven
regierungen zu protestieren zu diesem
zeitpunkt lebten mehr als 70 prozent der
über eine halbe milliarde facebook
nutzer außerhalb
in ägypten entzündete sich die wut an
einem fall von polizeibrutalität aber
der im mittelpunkt der proteste stand
ein google mitarbeiter der eine
war der manager einer seite in ägypten
die ein denkmal für einen typen war der
von der geheimpolizei geschlagen
gefoltert und getötet wurde
und diese gruppe wurde sehr sehr groß
viele viele hunderttausende von
mitgliedern während derzeit die zur
revolte gegen mubarak führte
[Musik]
mit facebook konnten die menschen
schneller ihre unzufriedenheit
ausdrücken was den prozess dieser
revolten deutlich beschleunigte
nachdem die regierungen von tunesien und
ägypten gestürzt waren
demonstranten auf den straßen facebooks
einer nannte seine neugeborene tochter
und cnn
ich würde gerne mark zuckerberg treffen
und ihm danken ich spreche im namen gibt
uns diese revolution begann auf facebook
als hunderttausende von ägyptern an
vielen informationen zusammen zu bringen
wenn wir ein video auf facebook posten
wurde es innerhalb weniger stunden von
50.000 menschen geteilt
facebook selbst hat versucht sich sehr
schnell von dieser politischen aktivität
zu distanzieren sie haben es wohl
unterstützt aber war nicht wirklich als
werkzeug dieser veränderung gesehen
worden facebook offensichtlich auch in
ländern wie china aktiv sein
sie wollen sich nicht als werkzeug des
aufstands
zuckerberg hat sich ein persönliches
ziel gesetzt dass ihm bei seiner mission
die welt zu verbinden helfen könnte eine
stunde am tag
eine milliarde neue freunde zu gewinnen
am schnellsten wachsende und größte
internetmarkt der welt es gibt hunderte
millionen von nutzern seine mission ist
vollständig wenn er nicht in china ist
mark zuckerbergs macht war nie größer
und wieder wuchsen die spekulationen
dass er sein unternehmen an die börse
bringen
200 jahren was wird dann wichtiger sei
das geld oder die tatsache dass er diese
art von einfluss hatte oder die tatsache
dass er dieses ding gemacht und mit
entwickelt hat
ist das nur eine technologie seite
und es ist mehr als nur eine website und
deshalb ging es nie um geld
und company esco pub in unternehmen an
die börse gehen ist das eine enorme
belastung für das management und
obendrein öffnet man sich bei einem
börsengang noch stärker der staatlichen
kontrolle
und diese kontrolle wissens bestärkte
facebook seine präsenz in einem team das
mehrere ehemalige berater des weißen
hauses und einflussreiche regierung
politische beamte werden dir sagen wenn
du bei der debatte nicht dabei bist
wirst du wahrscheinlich derjenige sein
der irgendwie ausgeschlossen wird
deswegen ist die anwesenheit in dieser
debatte vor allem wenn google yahoo
microsoft und viele andere große akteure
viel geld für lobbyarbeit ausgeben ein
fehler
freunde klassenkameraden das unternehmen
verlassen
[Musik]
top programmierer verlassen unternehmen
wie google zu dem teil von facebook und
facebook und google die beiden internet
giganten mehr konkurrieren auf andere
weise
die beziehung zwischen ziemlich einfach
sie mögen sie
sind sehr verschieden wissen
war irgendwie jung frech wild
und google ist wie ein algorithmus firma
aber sind typen die sind so für jedes
problem muss es einen weg geben einen
kleinen algorithmus zu schreiben der es
bewegt
es ist klar dass google in aufstieg der
sozialen netzwerke verpasst hat eric
schmidt hat zugegeben dass er auf
verlorenem posten stellt sie haben eine
reihe von dingen ausprobieren wenn das
soziale netzwerk war das einfach nicht
funktioniert im mai 2011 wurde facebook
in verlegenheit gebracht als bekannt
wurde dass es einen geheimen angriff auf
google gestartet hat
betreibt schadensbegrenzung nach der
enthüllung dass es eine pr firma
beauftragt hat negative geschichten über
google zu verbreiten fest behauptete
öffentlich das sei eine hetzkampagne
aber der austausch zeigte die bösartig
die konkurrenz geworden war die ganze
nation katastrophe war wirklich nur ein
offener ausdruck der feindseligkeit
nicht nur zwischen beiden unternehmen
entstanden war dann fast ein
persönliches chd expert drama das sich
zwischen google und facebook abspielt
auch viele ehemalige google
führungskräften sitzen die nichts mehr
täten als ihr früheres unternehmen zu
verdrängen
man kann nicht unterschätzen wie
ehrgeizig mark zuckerberg ist er sagt
seine mission ist es die welt offener
und zu einem besseren ort sonst für
seine mission ist es aber auch die
nummer eins zu sein ich glaube er wird
ein
weiteren harvard aussteiger zuckerberg
ein harter konkurrent im april 2012
besiegte er mit einer beeindruckenden
über die rivalen google und twitter
handumdrehen vom markt facebook mag die
photo sharing app so sehr dass es vor
dem börsengang eine milliarde dollar in
bar und aktien dafür bezahlt aber die
app ist kostenlos und hat kaum bekannte
einnahmen trotzdem braucht facebook
instagram vielmehr als instagram das
geld braucht instagram ist zu einem foto
sharing konkurrenten und einem eigenen
sozialen netzwerk geworden
kann es nicht riskieren dass ein anderes
soziales netzwerk das auch fotos
ausgerichtet ist eine vergleichbare
anziehungskraft entwickelt
ich glaube dass das eine präventive
qualität google war mit ziemlicher
sicherheit auch interessiert und so war
facebook vielleicht gezwungen zu handeln
das ist ein großartiger moment sehr zäh
um im kapuzenpulli und turnschuhen
verfügt über 57 prozent
stimmrecht facebook hat buchstäblich die
welt verändert wir sind vom lamm über
das dorf in die stadt zu facebook ich
glaube es wird immer größer und größer
und größer
eine website die es geschafft hat sich
vom schlaf sei zu einer plattform zu
entwickeln auf der meine 80 jährige
mutter und ich und mein chiropraktiker
und meine dritte klasse zusammen kommen
was zu besprechen haben das ist eine
leistung
er ist genauso visionär wie steve jobs
hat er sich als genauso einflussreich
erweisen wie bill gates aber er hat es
nicht mit einem spielzeug zu tun
mit irgendeinem programm
sondern mit unserem leben unserer
identität deshalb glaube ich dass wir
ihn alle in gewisser weise in schach
halten müssen
wir treffen unsere entscheidungen bei
facebook nicht gemein zu optimieren was
im nächsten jahr passieren würde sondern
um uns darauf vorzubereiten in einer
welt zu leben in der jede
produkterfahrung soziale alles von
facebook an
es begann mit einer einfachen frage
wurde aber zu einer der größten
erfolgsgeschichten des silicon valley so
etwas wie der puls des internets es ist
eine sirene für die freiheit zu glauben
dass der offene austausch von
informationen einen positiven globalen
einfluss haben kann ein megaphon für
politiker und ein roter teppich für
prominente die sich an ihre fans richten
um ein erfolgreiches start-up zu gründen
braucht man zwei grundlegende dinge
großartige gründer und die passende
gelegenheit bot pionierin williams mit
pastor und dem ursprünglichen erfinder
jack dorsey von diese gelegenheit in
twitter das auf über 500 millionen
registrierte nutzer angewachsen ist die
täglich über 55 millionen tweets
schreiben
twitter ermöglicht es habe sich der welt
mitzuteilen
es war schon überall aber die reise
verlief nicht immer reibungslos vor
allem nicht für die drei
verantwortlichen von anfang an gab es im
unternehmen spannungen darüber wie wir
den enthusiasmus für dieses sehr
einfache produkt in umsatz und gewinn
umwandeln können
[Musik]
willkommen und hallo wir sind hier um
über twitter zu sprechen
das produkt ist ein kurzer informations
ausbruch von 140 zeichen oder weniger
genannt tweet twitter wurde von diesen
drei männern gegründet evan williams
will stone und jack dorsey im juli 2011
bewertete eine finanzierungsrunde das
unternehmen mit 8 milliarden dollar
tim o'reilly ist verleger und
transporter in der tech szene
diese jungs haben etwas getan nicht weil
sie genau wussten wohin es führen würde
sondern weil sie dachten es sei an für
sich eine gute sache das sind meiner
meinung nach auf die wahren game changer
twitter-mitbegründer ist der blogger
vorreiter evan williams das beste und
schlechteste und sind zwei seiten
derselben zeit mappus ist gründer und
geschäftsführender partner der
risikokapitalgesellschaft flatrate und
einer der frühen investoren von twitter
glaube er stur wenn es darum geht die
ideen zu verfolgen die ihm am herzen
liegen oder was sich im laufe der zeit
zu schätzen gelernt habe ist dass er von
diesem glauben angetrieben wird als sohn
eines landwirts wurde williams 1972
geboren und wuchs auf der familien farm
in der nähe von clarks nebraska auf make
and williams seit ende der 90er jahre er
war das dritte von vier kindern und sein
vater und dessen vater ging gerne auf
die jagd und erwin ist veganer also
denke ich dass er sich so ein bisschen
eingefügt hat im ländlichen nebraska wo
er aufwuchs gibt es nicht viele soja
trinkende veganer auf den benachbarten
farmen somit war williams leidenschaft
nicht die landwirtschaft sondern
webdesign und programmierung nach
eineinhalb jahren an der universität von
nebraska brach sein studium ab und trieb
sich in verschiedenen top jobs und
startups herum ich habe mein erstes
unternehmen 1994 in der briesker
gegründet wozu ich erst einmal erklären
musste was das internet überhaupt ist
einmalig ist gründer des tech-blogs
gigaom und schreibt seit über einem
jahrzehnt über das internet angeht nicht
zur schule um unternehmer zu werden
entweder man hat es oder man hat es
nicht oder und es scheint es einfach zu
haben er wurde damit geboren die
fähigkeit chancen zu erkennen ist
angeboren sie steckt in der dns und ich
denke er will gehört zu dieser gruppe
mensch dies einfach weiß
er nahm diesen unternehmergeist mit in
den westen in das mekka für
technikfreaks nach nordkalifornien
sein erster job
er hatte immer eine meinung dazu wie die
dinge besser werden könnten er war nie
zufrieden mit dem status quo
er in hatten die hemmungen uns
mitzuteilen was seiner meinung nach
nicht funktionierte und wie wir es
besser machen könnten
innerhalb eines jahres arbeitete
williams als unabhängige programmierer
zum schreiben von code für unternehmen
wie intel und hewlett packard
in san francisco tat er sich mit der
software unternehmerin mary ham zusammen
sie wurden ein paar und gründeten
gemeinsam das unternehmen pyra labs
das ist also mein schreibtisch sehr
unordentlich als ihr power gründeten war
das 1999 genau auf dem höhepunkt der
dotcom blase es war wirklich aufregend
zu der zeit in san francisco zu sein
relapse produkt war dazu gemacht
projekte zu verwalten den überblick über
aufgabenlisten zu behalten und kontakte
zu knüpfen ein kleines feature war ein
von williams erfundenes tool das die
aktualisierung eines persönlichen online
tagebuchs erleichterte dass damals
bekannt war als
dann entschied ein freund von uns
scherzhaft dass er es nicht weblog
sondern blog nennen würde
williams ein neues produkt evan es
wirklich gut mit branding und so er
sagte wir sollten erst globalen
blogger.com wurde zu einer sensation
ich konnte es kaum glauben jeden tag gab
es mehr besucher auf der webseite mehr
nutzer meldeten sich an ist es konnte
unmöglich so weiter gehen und am
nächsten tag waren es wieder mehr leute
journalist und berichtet über die
tech-branche niemand wusste wirklich was
blogs sind er hatte die idee dass er
eine einfache möglichkeit schaffen
wollte online ein artikel zu
veröffentlichen was kurzes über sein
leben zu schreiben und es zu
veröffentlichen es war ein neues
das bloggen bildete diese brillante
zusätzliche ebene dies ermöglichte nur
mit dem inhalt zu arbeiten nur mit den
bildern man musste nichts technisches
tun und so wurde das web wirklich zum
web für jedermann aber
die große idee des kleinen start ups war
nicht genug um es über wasser zu halten
tatsächlich traf es einen eisberg
der markt crash im jahre 2000 war eine
katastrophe für viele im silicon valley
die leute waren in panik dot com drohte
zu scheitern sie war nicht darauf
vorbereitet wie schnell alles irgendwie
zusammenbrechen könnte uns ging das geld
aus ich verließ das unternehmen weil ich
enorm gestresst und gereizt war und
fünfstellige schulden hatte und eben
schloss den laden und brachte die server
zurück in seine wohnung und kümmerte
sich zusammen um den sturm der post
dot-com-blase irgendwie zu überstehen
die post dot-com-blase hässlichen san
francisco man hatte diese ganze gruppe
von leuten die dachten sie würden auf
den zug zum reichtum aufspringen und
dann mussten sie sich plötzlich nach
einem alternativen lebensweg umschauen
williams postete in seinem blog dass er
jetzt der einzige angestellte bei
blogger sei es gab einige ziemlich
düstere phasen und viele unternehmer
haben aufgegeben aber eben blieb dran
wenn man ein großer unternehmer ist muss
man bereit sein ein paar dinge
auszuprobieren und wenn man seine arbeit
nicht liebt wenn man auf heftigen
widerstand oder dummheit oder trägheit
stößt die die welt vor deine füße wirft
wird man aufgeben du wirst zwar nicht
durchhalten aber wenn du eine idee
wirklich liebst bist du davon überzeugt
dass du recht und der rest der welt
einfach unrecht hat so dass du einfach
weiter am ball bleibt und das wird es
sein dass sich letztendlich am leben
hält der ven williams leitete
blogger.com allein das unternehmen hatte
zu kämpfen und überlebte gerade so die
dot.com pleite er hatte nichts mehr
außer seiner idee als er einen anruf
eines branchenriesen erhielt er rief
seine ehemalige partnerin mccann an und
teilte ihr die neuigkeiten mit er fragte
sitzt du gerade und ich sagte ja nein
wirklich sitzt du gerade sagte er und
ich sagte ja ich sitze er sagte wir
haben gerade ein angebot von google
erhalten die summe des verkaufs wurde
nie bekannt gegeben das ist so als würde
man in der zweiten liga spielen und dann
rufen plötzlich die yankees sein und
sagen weißt du was ich möchte dass du
bei den play offs mitmachst google war
riesig sie waren cool und sie waren auf
dem vormarsch was ziemlich aufregend war
oder ich habe den perfekten zeitpunkt
erwischt google war auf dem vormarsch
und williams war dabei er begann mit der
entwicklung von blogger.com für den
explodierenden suchgiganten während
dieser zeit war sein zukünftiger
geschäftspartner bis 3000 meilen weit
entfernt an der ostküste und arbeitete
als kreativdirektor an einer
konkurrierenden blocking website namens
xing.com
patrick ist autor und kommentator für
technologie und soziale medien
vom typ her ein rebell
ich glaube er ist sehr witzig und bissig
und macht gerne scherze stone sprang auf
den block in zug auf ihm gefiel aber
kein gas aus richtung nicht 2001 zucker
unter der leitung von schenker nach los
angeles und schrieb zwei bücher übers
bloggen auch stone erhielt einen anruf
und google und wurde eingestellt um dem
unternehmen bei der klum seiner
neuanschaffung blogger.com zu
unterstützen so trafen sich die beiden
zukünftigen geschäftspartner von twitter
zum allerersten mal 1999 evan und ich
waren im grunde genommen rivalen in
rivalisierenden firmen-events schickte
mir eine nachricht mit den worten wie
wäre es wenn du für mich arbeiten würde
das erste mal trafen wir uns also als er
mich vom flughafen abholte um mich zur
arbeit zu fahren aber ihre zeit im
unternehmen war begrenzt nach weniger
als zwei jahren verließ williams kugel
im oktober 2004 er hat ja noch nie für
jemanden oder in einem unternehmen
gearbeitet er ist ein erfinder ein
unternehmer er will die dinge genau dann
aufbauen können wenn sie ihm einfallen
ende 2004 schrieb williams einen
business plan für ein neues internet
startup namens audio ein podcasting
unternehmen das audios im internet
verbreiten und veröffentlichen sollte er
sammelte 5 milliarden dollar von einigen
der größten namen im bereich angel money
und risikokapital darunter google
geldgeber ron conway lotus gründer mit
kapoor und sein alter chef bei o'reilly
media tim o'reilly
nach dem essen mit blogger erfolgreich
war fiel es ihm relativ leicht angel
money und risikokapital gelder von der
idee zu überzeugen
das podcasting die neue generation des
bloggens werden würde
verließ google und schloss sich williams
bei audio an doch das junge unternehmen
erlitt einen vernichtenden schlag audio
prallte auf eine unsichtbare mauer
namens apple michaels hat 25.000 dollar
in orio investiert wir wollten podcasts
der breiten masse zugänglich machen und
eine woche nachdem ein check bekommen
hatte wurde apple plötzlich podcast auf
itunes sein wenn man podcast anbietet
muss dafür auch noch passende
wiedergabegeräte ist nicht mehr klar ob
man selbst damit überhaupt noch ein
geschäft machen konnte innerhalb von
sechs monaten nach gründung des podcast
dem unternehmens audiolith evan williams
erfolgsgeschichte auf dem silicon valley
einen dämpfer
[Musik]
audios web musik vertriebsunternehmen am
ende des jahres 2005 tot und jeder im
silicon valley wusste davon
ich hielt nicht viel von dir und ich
dachte so ein podcasting unternehmen
wäre irrelevant
während die aussichten des unternehmens
düster schienen tat sich am horizont ein
licht auf herbert jack dorsey im jahre
2005 führte durch sein eigenes startup
an ein selbst ernannter computerfreak
als kind war doch sie besessen von
karten
tapezierte sein ganzes zimmer mit karten
von nahverkehrssystemen
straßenkarten der stadtautobahn und als
seine familie schließlich am computer
anschaffte erkannte er dass er im grunde
genommen seine eigenen karten auf dem pc
zeichnen könnte er seine dort als
erwachsener verlagerte sich seine
besessenheit hin zur entwicklung von
software systemen für das sofortige
versenden von nachrichten
für notrufzentralen kuriere und taxis
das konzept war ganz einfach das ist das
was ich mache und jeder der daran
interessiert ist kann es in echtzeit
mitverfolgen
sie hatte jahrelang versucht das
potenzial eines versand systems zu
erforschen das freunden helfen konnte
miteinander in kontakt zu bleiben nach
einer zufälligen begegnung mit williams
glaubte er seine chance erkannt zu haben
zu diesem zeitpunkt musste ich mir einen
richtigen job suchen und habe ein
lebenslauf geschrieben ich bin ein sehr
einfacher programmierer und habe diesen
aspekt immer ging aber ich wollte etwas
anderes machen und ich hatte von einem
anderen blogger von ebner fahren beim
mittagessen auf einem kinderspielplatz
beschrieb dorsey die idee die er seit
seiner jugend mit sich herumtrug
das einfachste was wir tun können ist
von meinem handy aus eine nachricht zu
verschicken die andere leute in echtzeit
lesen können er drängte williams dazu in
das ausprobieren zu lassen und sagte
lasst es uns machen das ist so leicht zu
programmieren dass wir es wohl in zwei
tagen schaffen können
williams gab ihm zwei wochen zeit
keystone darum ihm bei der entwicklung
der grafiken und visuelle elemente zu
helfen zwei wochen später hatten sie was
wir haben ein system aufgestellt mit dem
wir sofort eine nachricht verfassen
konnten damit konnte man mit einem 20
dollar nokia handy eine nachricht
schreiben dass man gerade mitten im
central park in new york city ist und
gänse auf dem see vorbeiziehen sieht und
die nachricht würde sofort an alle
freunde in echtzeit verschickt werden am
21 märz 2006 verschickte die erste
nachricht
das produkt funktionierte aber das
freundschafts system brauchte einen
einprägsamen namen
noah glass einer der mitbegründer von
oreo durchforstete das oxford english
dictionary und stieß auf twitter kurze
information aus hofe beziehungsweise
gezwitscher von vögeln das passte
perfekt und es war genau das was wir
machten
williams kaufte sich bei audio aus und
gründete ein neues unternehmen das im
april 2007 zu twitter wurde das kostete
ihn zwei millionen dollar in sagte zu
mir dass wir einfach nicht glauben
würden dass wir hiermit ein geschäft
machen könnten und anstatt allgäuer geld
auszugeben und zu versuchen etwas neues
zu erfinden oder das rad weiter zu
drehen werde ich euch einfach euer geld
zurück und tatsächlich haben viele der
leute mit denen ich in odeo investiert
hatte ihr geld zurückbekommen wer damals
nicht in twitter investiert hat die
verfolgtes bis heute
vorstandsvorsitzender stone war kreativ
direktor und der wortkarge jack dorsey
war der erste ceo von twitter
er will dachte eine zeit lang darüber
nach und kam dann zu dem schluss dass
jack die logische wahl als video wäre er
hatte keine erfahrungen irgendetwas
außer in der codierung er war keine
führungspersönlichkeit und so war es
durchaus ein wagnis ihn zum
geschäftsführer zu machen
[Musik]
es war dieses musikfestival das twitter
zum durchbruch verhalf das jährliche
south by southwest music and technology
festival in austin texas brachte twitter
in 2007 die nötige öffentlichkeit
twitter
[Musik]
ich möchte mich bei allen bedanken in
140 zeichen oder weniger ich habe es
gerade geschafft danke
wir haben zwei bildschirme gemietet sie
in den fluren aufgestellt und darüber
anzeigen lassen was die leute über south
by southwest zusagen halten
wir twitter bei diesem festival zum
ersten mal in freier wildbahn
beobachteten sahen wir wie die leute zu
einer einheit verschmolzen und wir haben
diese idee eines spaßigen festivals
weitergesponnen was wäre wenn das bei
anderen veranstaltungen auf der ganzen
welt der fall wäre twitter hatte seinen
höhepunkt erreicht während des festivals
verdreifachten sich die abgesetzten
tweets von 20.000 auf 60.000 tweets pro
tag
später tauchte zu einer zeit auf als es
seinen demografischen wandel in der
computer nutzung gab als computer nicht
länger nur produktivitäts werkzeuge
waren sondern soziale werkzeuge über die
man sich mitteilen konnte auf twitter
wurde schnell zu einem tool um
mitzuteilen was ich gerade lese ich
gerade denke wo ich gerade bin bin ich
gerade sehe aber
williams und sein team waren auf diesen
ansturm nicht gut vorbereitet wie
williams später charlie rose zählte wir
hatten in den ersten eineinhalb jahren
eine schreckliche phase in der die seite
auf zusammenbrach und sehr langsam war
und wir brauchten lange um das zu
beheben das hat uns das genick gebrochen
glaube ich
es gab interne spannungen in der firma
dorf sie hatte es als ceo schwer
er bekam keinen respekt weil nicht klar
war wozu dieses produkt überhaupt diente
zum einen hatte er als die eu keine
erfahrung keine wirkliche autorität weil
er immer noch in einer firma arbeitete
die von evan kontrolliert wurde und zum
anderen ein produkt das ständig
abstürzte das einzig gute war dass
twitter ordentlich abgehängt
der druck wuchs am 16 oktober 2008
lockte williams dass das unternehmen
eine fokussierte herangehensweise einer
einzigen führungskraft benötige der
ursprüngliche erfinder dort trat als ceo
zurück und williams übernahm
jack war am boden zerstört denn twitter
war genau das worüber check in gewisser
weise sein ganzes leben nachgedacht
hatte aus dem unternehmen gedrängt zu
werben war einfach niederschmetternd er
brauchte monate lang um sich davon zu
erholen
twitter befand sich auf jedermanns radar
und das schloss einen sehr
interessierten potenziellen konkurrenten
facebook an den rand gedrängt werden
twitter war eine internationale
sensation
allein in einem jahr stieg die zahl der
abonnenten der social networking und
microblogging website um mehr als 1300
prozent wie gehen sie mit all der
aufmerksamkeit rund um twitter um
das hat die aufmerksamkeit des facebook
gründers mark zuckerberg erregt
ich habe das gefühl dass magdeburg
wahrscheinlich eine vision hatte wohin
auf facebook bringen will
und er hat wahrscheinlich twitter auf
dem weg zu seiner vision gesehen
zuckerberg versuchte das twitter
geschäft zu übernehmen
business week berichtete dass er 500
millionen dollar in bar und facebook
aktien angeboten hatte was evan williams
ablehnte
bis 2008 kosteten die nutzer 300.000
tweets pro tag
darunter auch oprah winfrey und
dabei sollte es nicht bleiben
[Musik]
robert zu sein war nicht so wichtig wie
die aufforderung des außenministeriums
an twitter die täglichen
wartungsarbeiten zu unterlassen weil die
iranischen wahlen via twitter übertragen
wurden
nach dem angeblichen betrug bei den
iranischen wahlen 2009 gingen die
menschen auf die straße die behörden des
landes zensierten handy nachrichten
zeitungen und websites die über die
zunehmend gewalttätigen protestaktionen
berichteten und damit die traditionelle
nachrichten und den mainstream in den
hintergrund stellte twitter wurde für
die außenwelt so wichtigsten
informationsquelle über den iran wir
mögen keine zensur wir glauben dass der
offene austausch von informationen einen
positiven einfluss auf die ganze welt
haben kann gewann schon immer für die
gemeinsame nutzung von informationen für
die demokratisierung von informationen
mehr informationen sind besser
ende 2009 stieg die zahl der tweets auf
zweieinhalb millionen pro tag aber
stephen colbert ließ das kalt
mein gast heute abend ist er
mitbegründer von twitter warum nur 140
zeichen schreiben zu kompliziert
als limit für texte sind 160 zeichen wir
wollten ein bisschen platz für einen
benutzernamen reservieren also haben wir
140 zeichen festgelegt die kreativität
der kurznachrichten wird sie überraschen
jeder sprach über twitter aber eine
große frage beschäftigte die gründer
immer noch wie machen wir geld ich
glaube nicht dass erin und biss toni die
straße entlang gehen konnten ohne dass
jemand flüstert wie vor dir bitte geld
verdienen wie geht es dieses jahr weiter
auf der ersten entwickler konferenz von
twitter im april 2010 haben die gründer
zum ersten mal einen plan vorgestellt
der aufzeigte wie das unternehmen geld
verdienen könnte wir gehen davon aus
dass die anzeigenschaltung lee
gesponserten tweet die wir gerade
starten oder diese woche gestartet haben
in ein paar monaten sicherlich den
größten teil ausmachen werden aber es
wird eine weile dauern gesponserte
tweets erlauben es den leuten auf
transparente art und weise botschaften
zu werbezwecken leute zu versenden die
twitter streams folgen und es wird
interessant sein zu sehen wie es
funktioniert ich denke dass das
unternehmen weiß dass es sich um eine
laufende entwicklung handelt am vierten
oktober 2010 kann die nachricht dass
evan williams als ceo des unternehmens
zurücktritt
twitter ist zu einem riesigen
unternehmen herangewachsen und muss sich
trotzdem erst noch als unternehmen
bewähren ich denke dass evan williams
sich nicht als der richtige sei für die
leitung von twitter erwiesen hat
sie ihr sein nachfolger sollte der
ehemalige ceo dick costolo werden wir
wachsen einfach in einem absurden tempo
ich habe schon ein paar andere
unternehmen geleitet und ein paar jahre
bei google verbracht aber dieses
wachstumstempo ist einfach nicht
vergleichbar ich habe noch nie so etwas
gesehen
de castello einer der langjährigen
bekannten größen im silicon valley ist
auch wenn er ceo ist immer noch in der
operative gewinn ist ein in denen aber
kein ziel
williams sagte er habe castro gebeten
den job zu übernehmen damit er sich voll
und ganz auf die produktstrategie
konzentrieren könne aber das
stühlerücken and wird das chefetage ging
im märz 2011 weiter der weggang von
williams öffnete die tür für den
ursprünglichen erfinder jack dorsey der
in eine wichtige rolle zurückkehrte
nämlich als executive chairman
dort twitterte er sei begeistert davon
wieder bei twitter zu arbeiten es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich dass sich die
innovation in den letzten paar jahren
verlangsamt hat und dass twitter zwar
dramatisch gewachsen ist allerdings ohne
sich maßgeblich zu verändern es gab von
anfang an ein problem mit twitter es war
zwar eine wirklich tolle technologie
aber niemand wusste wirklich was diese
für das unternehmen bedeutet das ist ein
problem dass das unternehmen im gewissen
maße bis heute verfolgt aber das hat die
besessenheit der welt von twitter nicht
gezügelt für narzissten ist ein traum
wahr geworden aber auch für journalisten
prominente medienleute marken
buchstäblich für jeden der ein großes
publikum mit einer reihe von nachrichten
erreichen will
peter wirkt sich auf die weltgeschichte
aus es gibt nicht viele unternehmen die
das tun
es steht außer frage dass twitter teil
des gefüges unserer gesellschaft wird
eine art und weise wie menschen
miteinander kommunizieren wie
nachrichten verbreitet werden es ist das
zwitschern von vögeln diese art der
kommunikation die wir nicht verstehen
und die doch überaus wichtig ist